so first thanks to the thanks to the
organizers for for having me this has
been a very educational conference so
far and I'm excited to tell you guys
about this project called first price
auctions with general information
structures and its joint work with with
two individuals who should be well known
to this audience so before diving in I
just wanted to to frame the exercise you
know I think it's it's kind of useful to
talk about how this work fits in with
the shared perspective that you know the
cs and econ crowd have so you know those
papers going to be about first price
auctions and the classical methodology
for thinking about first price auctions
that that comes from Vickery would be to
say let's fix an information of values
you know victory started with an
independent distribution over the
bidders values and fix an assumption
about the knowledge that the bidders
have namely that values are independent
and private you know the IPV set up
meaning that I know my value but I don't
know anything about others values except
that it's drawn from this independent
prior that everyone knows and and one
way to view the agt perspective is to
say that you know this model is is not
quite right you know when once you've
specified all this it's great because
you can do all sorts of interesting
things with it you can talk about
welfare properties of first price
auctions you can compare that mechanism
to other mechanisms but it's not quite
right in the sense that you know when in
the real world do we ever know exactly
what F is so when do we ever feel that
confident in the assumptions of our
model that were basing these predictions
on and so a GT says you know let's think
about predictions about welfare outcomes
in the in the first price auction that
aren't so sensitive to the assumption of
a particular distribution F that's very
F and see what happens okay now the
exercise that I'm going to talk about
today is in a sense complementary to
this perspective we're also going to
take a point of view that the classical
model isn't quite right but not because
of the distribution of values but
because of this assumption about
information
okay and we're going to say when in the
real world are we that confident that
the bidders just know their own value
and don't know anything about others
values or when are we that confident to
to write down a particular parametric
form for what that information should
look like so our exercise is going to be
about making predictions about behavior
in the auction where we vary information
and of course you know you can also
think about combining these two
exercises and saying what can we say
about behavior in the auction where
we're varying distribution of
fundamentals and also varying
information and to my knowledge there
are people in this room who are working
on that combination on that combined
exercise but for today I'm just going to
focus on on this piece okay so that's
that's my basic preamble and set up now
let me give you a model so this is a
special case of the general model that
we analyze there are two bidders and
these guys compete in the first price
auction for a single unit of a good
these guys have single unit demand okay
so it's a very very simple setup and
they actually have the same value which
is a V that's uniformly distributed
between 0 and 1 okay and in the auction
these guys submit bids which are
non-negative real numbers the person who
submits the highest bid is going to win
and get the good and they have to pay
their bids so the surplus is b minus B
okay so because everyone has the same
value and the good is always allocated
efficiency isn't really a concern in
this setting surplus is always going to
be a half right which is just the
expectation of this value but the
distribution of that surplus between the
buyers in the seller is sort of what's
at issue and what we'd like to
understand better so the settlers
revenue is going to be the expected
maximum bid and then the bidders are
going to get the rest right and the
broad question is what are the
predictions we can make about how the
surplus is going to be split in
equilibrium but at this point the model
isn't completely specified because you
know I've described the distribution of
the value but I haven't said what the
bidders know about the value I have to
fill that in so in particular what do
they know about the value yeah
I've assumed that the value is uniformly
distributed between 0 & 1 so it has an
expectation of a half that's all and
it's a pure common value everyone has
the same value thank you there's a front
the total value mind is the price or
it's just tonight this is the ex-ante
value of the good the total surplus
that's going to be generated by the
oxygen for the buyers and the seller so
I have to say what they know about the
value I also have to say what they know
about what others know about the value
etc right I have to specify higher-order
beliefs and there are many possible ways
to do this so for example I could say
the bidders don't know anything except
for the prior and in that case everybody
thinks that the good has a value of a
half you're not learning anything about
the value from the outcome of the
auction so the unique equilibrium is
going to be you know bertrand
competition and the price is going to be
exactly a half and the seller gets all
of the surpluses revenue here's an
extreme opposite a bitter see everything
and they know that everybody sees
everything in this case we both know
that the values V and again we're going
to compete the value up to V in
expectation the seller is still going to
extract all the rents in the bidders get
0 okay but of course you know the true
information structure we think is likely
to be something in between it's not
going to be no information it's not
going to be but but the bidders are
going to have some information about the
value and some information about what
others think about the value but it's
it's not that easy to introspectively
conclude exactly how much information
the bidder should have so here's an
example of an intermediate information
structure there are many that I could
have given but but here's one and this
is an example from engelbrecht Milgram
web n Gobrecht Wiggins no groom and
Weber i love that bitter one is an
informed bitter and he sees the value
exactly bitter too doesn't see anything
ok now in this situation bitter to
strategy has to be independent to the
value of the good because he doesn't
know anything about it but bitter one
can correlate his bid with the value and
that means that in equilibrium bitter
two might be learning something about
the value from the event that he wins
because he only wins when the when his
bid is bigger than the other
right it turns out that there's an
equilibrium in the setting again
assuming the uniform distribution where
the informed bitter just bids half the
value and the uninformed bidder
randomizes between zero and a half
uniformly so let me quickly try to
convince you that this is an equilibrium
let's first think about the uninformed
bitter so the uninformed bitter is
basically facing adverse selection
because of the way that the informed bid
is correlated with the value if the
uninformed guy bids some be too then
he's going to win whenever the other
guys bid is less than B 2 which is when
the value is less than twice the bid
because the informed guy is bidding half
at the value okay now what's the
expectation of the value drawn from a
uniform prior given that it's less than
twice be too it's exactly be too so
basically no matter what the Sun
informed guy bids his expected value
conditional on winning it's going to be
exactly equal to his bit so you get zero
he's indifferent she's happy to
randomize the informed bidder on the
other hand thinks that he's facing this
uniform distribution so the surplus that
he gets from a bit of b1 is going to be
V minus b1 times some linear term in the
bid and you know it's not real pretty
good at calculus so it's easy to
conclude that the optimal thing in this
case is to bid half the value so this is
an equilibrium and it's also not hard to
see that now the bidders are going to
get some surplus for themselves because
basically this inform bidder is always
shading and there's a positive
probability that is going to win so he
has to be getting some positive rents
and in particular he gets a sixth
the takeaway from this example is that
the way we model information has a big
impact on the outcome of the auction
okay and the reason is that your optimal
bid depends on not just what you think
the value is but also on what you think
others are going to bid and of course
that depends on what they think the
value is and what they think others are
going to bid etc so the equilibrium
depends in a kind of complicated way on
everyone's higher-order beliefs and this
is as opposed to say a second price
auction where you know if you make
stronger assumptions like everyone at
least knows their value the second price
auction doesn't have this dependence on
higher-order beliefs because I always
have a weekly dominant strategy to bid
my value not the case in the first price
auction but as we were saying before a
problem is that it's hard to say which
is the correct specification for
information it's hard to point to a
situation in the real world where we
observe beliefs directly or that they're
easy that they're easy to measure okay
so it's hard it's hard to test the
assumptions that we make so our exercise
is going to be what are the predictions
we can make about welfare that don't
depend on how we model information so
here is a brief overview of the results
of the paper before I before I go back
to the example so basically we study a
generalized version of this model the
value doesn't have to be common there
can be idiosyncratic component two
values and we basically but although for
many of the results will assume that
that distribution is symmetric and we
leave unspecified the information that
the bidders have about everybody's
values and what we do is we characterize
tight bounds on welfare outcomes namely
we say what is the maximum revenue that
could obtain minimum revenue that could
obtain maximum bitter surplus minimum
bitter surplus as we range over all
possible specifications for information
and all equilibria Bayesian equilibrium
yes Rhea aren't you assuming that the
bitter snow but the other guy
no yes so there is some asymmetry of
information assume between our
perspective as a kind of outside
researcher and the agents who are who
are involved in the auction they know
what the environment is and we don't and
we're trying to make predictions about
it so I agree that you know that's an
assumption and it's worth thinking about
but it's a certainly a natural
perspective to take I think for certain
certain situations okay and I and I just
want to emphasize again that these
predictions that we make are for a given
and fixed distribution of values so in
print you know you could in principle
use this exercise to compute bounds over
a range of value distributions using as
an input the bounds that we obtain
conditional on each value distribution
if that's your cup of tea okay and then
you know I would say that this fits into
a kind of broader objective you know the
first price auction is just one
mechanism it turns out that the analysis
of that one mechanism is kind of
involved but more broadly you know we'd
like to replicate this exercise for a
range of mechanisms and talk about set
valued predictions for outcomes and have
a somewhat more agnostic but safer a way
of comparing the performance of
mechanisms and I already talked about
complementarity with with other
perspectives that are represented in the
room probably the alarm is going to go
off at any second but absolutely or you
can stretch your legs or welcome if you
got them
here we go that's not very disruptive at
all I'm going to just keep going okay
how low can revenue go in this uniform
example okay that's that's what I want
to explore next it can't go all the way
to zero that's a that's a pretty cheap
conclusion why the only way that revenue
could be zero is if everyone is bidding
zero all the time but of course there's
got to be some bitter who thinks that
they have a positive value sometimes and
if they follow this purported
equilibrium everyone is tying at zero
but you could bid an epsilon and win all
the time okay and then of course you'd
have an incentive to deviate in that
manner so revenue can't be exactly zero
it also seems likely that it can go
below the level in this Engelbrecht
wiggins Milgram Weber example that I
gave you before the reason is that at
minimum revenue there's some sense in
which the winning bid distribution is
pushed down as low as it can go ok
what's the force that's going to be
preventing it from going lower it must
be that if it were to go lower some
bitter would have an incentive to
deviate to a higher bid you know as in
the thought experiment about zero
revenue someone would want to deviate to
a bit larger than zero so but in the EMW
example the informed bidder actually
strictly prefers is equilibrium bit over
any other bit right he has this concave
objective function V minus B times B and
and V over 2 is a unique global optimum
and actually I could even use that
example to construct other examples that
are symmetric in which everyone has a
strict incentive to follow their
equilibrium strategy so it's kind of not
passing are our suspicions that lots of
upward incentive constraints should be
binding at minimum revenue let me give
you another construction okay
in this specification for information
the bidders are going to get signals and
these signals are going to be numbers
between zero and one one of the bidders
is going to get a precise signal that's
exactly equal to the true value the
other bidder is going to get a noisy
signal which is distributed below the
true value according to this particular
cumulative distribution function square
root of the signal over the value so and
and you know one of these guys is going
to get a precise signal one's going to
get a noisy signal they don't know who
is who we're going to randomize and
they're going to be equally likely and
of course there's the same support for
signals so you can't tell from which
signal you got whether or not it was a
precise or a noisy signal exactly my
claim is that this is there's an
equilibrium in this setting which is to
bid your signal over three one third
your signal so before I attempt to
convince you that this is in fact the
equilibrium let me explore some
consequences of it the guy who who wins
according to this monotonic strategy is
going to be the bidder who got the
higher signal and the bidder who got the
higher signal is always the guy who got
the precise signal so that means that in
equilibrium the winning bid is always
going to be one-third of the value and
since the value is uniformly distributed
revenue is going to be a sixth it's a
symmetric equilibrium and information
structure the bidders are going to get
16 surplus each they don't they just
know their signal but it could have come
from either the precise signal or the
noisy signal and they're equally likely
ex ante okay let me try to convince you
that this is in equilibrium yes I don't
know but but I know that it's the worst
equilibrium in terms of revenue and
since my objective is to minimize you
know revenue I'm looking for the minimum
revenue that's sufficient for my
purposes but I don't know if it's unique
okay let me try to convince you this is
an equilibrium that this is an
equilibrium for every signal we can
think about deviating up or deviating
down let's think about deviating down
first you got the signal s if it was
noisy you know that the other guy must
have gotten a higher signal so if you
follow your equilibrium strategy you're
getting zero surplus in that event and
if you deviate down you're still going
to lose and you're still going to get
zero surplus so we kind of don't care
about what happens if you deviate down
and the signal was noisy on the other
hand if you got the precise signal then
the other guy signal was lower okay and
you're still going to win with some
positive probability if you deviate down
and we have to do the the calculus to
determine whether or not you'd want to
so this is actually the surplus that
you'd get you're going to deviate down
to a bid s prime over 3 your surplus
will be s minus s prime over 3 because
remember you got the precise signal so
this is the true value of the good and
the other guys signal is distributed
according to this distribution as prime
over s square rooted ok now you can
hopefully follow Ben's prescription
yesterday and Trust now verify later
that I've done the calculus correctly
and the derivative of this expression is
positive as long as s prime is less than
s which corresponds to a downward
deviation okay so no one wants to
deviate down let's think about the other
side now if you deviate up to a higher
bid we can decompose your surplus into
two pieces again there's the event that
you got the precise signal in which case
you were going to win by following the
equilibrium strategy you're still going
to win with the higher bid and but
you're now going to have to pay more
because this s prime over 3 is higher
than your equilibrium bit of s over 3 on
the other hand you might have gotten the
noisy signal and now you're going to win
on some events where you would have lost
in equilibrium and you know intuitively
there are a bunch of values now for
which you might win which is when the
winning bid would be above s over 3 but
below as prime over 3 okay and you're
going to wait those events by the
relative likelihood of you having
received as noisy signal conditional on
that being the true value you can
hopefully trust me that this is the
correct specification take the
derivative again
and it turns out to be zero in other
words the bidders are exactly
indifferent to deviating up to any
higher bid that's in the support of
equilibrium bids so the bottom line is
that in this equilibrium there are lots
of binding upward constraints in fact
all of the upward and set of constraints
are binding okay and my claim is that
this is the information structure and
equilibrium that minimizes revenue I'm
not going to give you the complete proof
but I'm going to give you a partial
proof I'm going to prove to you that
this equilibrium minimizes revenue
within a restricted class of information
structures in equilibrium okay so you
notice that the no information
equilibrium the complete information
equilibrium and the one that I
constructed all have the feature that
the winning bid is a deterministic
function of the true value right in no
information it was always a half
deterministic function in the complete
information case it was always the true
value and in mic in my construction it
was one-third of the value okay so in
all three cases it's a deterministic and
in the last two strictly increasing
function of the value so I want to think
about equilibria of that form in which
the winning bid ends up being
deterministic strictly increasing
actually and also symmetric I want the
equilibria be symmetric so that both
bidders are equally likely to win at any
given winning bid okay now in any
equilibrium bidders have to not want to
deviate from their equilibrium
strategies and the question is what
restriction does that place on this beta
function right beta is sufficient for
calculating revenue in the auction and I
want to see what constraints come from
the equilibrium conditions
I want to look at a class of deviations
of a very particular form and we call
these uniform upward deviations and
basically what they say is this there's
a uniform upward deviation for every bid
and the deviation says whenever in
equilibrium you would have been less
than this level deviate up to that level
if you were going to bid higher keep
bidding what you were going to bid but
if you were going to bit less deviate up
okay and of course you know this is a
feasible deviation for the players and
so in equilibrium they can't want to
uniformly deviate up and actually you
can formulate the uniform upward
deviation constraint just in terms of
this beta function okay if you deviate
up in this manner there are two things
that going to happen one is whenever you
are going to win in equilibrium you're
still going to win because you've
deviated up but now you're going to pay
more right so in particular whenever you
were going to get a winning bid between
beta of 0 and beta V you're still going
to win but you're going to pay beta V
instead of beta of X and in ex-ante
terms that happens with probability half
because it's a symmetric equilibrium on
the other hand you might gain from
winning when you would have lost when
are you going to win well you'll win
whenever the other guy was going to win
with probability a half at a bid beta X
with X less than V and in that case
you'll get the true value of the good
which is X because the other guy bids as
a deterministic function of the true
value when he's winning minus this bid
that you've deviated up to okay you can
rearrange this inequality to conclude
that beta V has to be greater than this
expression now we want to minimize
revenue revenue is just going to be the
expectation of this beta function so on
the whole decreasing beta is going to
lower revenue so an intermediate
question is what is the smallest beta
could be subject to the restriction that
it be non-negative and that it's
satisfied this inequality and it's not
too hard to conclude actually that the
optimum for that problem has to solve
this equality inequality as an equality
everywhere at least in the support
okay and the reason is that on the whole
lowering beta lowers revenue so if this
constraint we're slack it would mean you
can lower beta V without giving anyone
an incentive to uniformly deviate up to
that point but actually lowering beta
lowers the right-hand side as well so it
further relaxes the constraint meaning
that this perturbation is feasible okay
and you can verify that the solution
with beta of zero equals zero and
satisfying this constraint with
inequality gives you beta V equals view
/ 3 so in other words the equilibrium
that we constructed solves a relaxation
of the original problem where we just
optimize over this winning bid function
subject to these uniform upward
deviation constraints and in fact you
don't need to assume symmetry and you
don't need to assume this deterministic
winning bid even if the winning bid is
allowed to be asymmetric and stochastic
conditional and true value of the good
it has to be the case that any
equilibrium winning bid distribution has
to first order stochastically dominate
the winning bid distribution in the
example which was uniform between zero
and a third and so 16 is a global lower
bound on revenue and equilibrium in this
setting so there are a bunch of
methodological connections of this work
I haven't attempted to you have an
exhausted list by any means but the
stuff that I think is most closely
related with in economics is the stuff
that you know I have worked on with
co-authors and co-authors co-authors on
robust predictions and games of
incomplete information but obviously
there's also a deep connection to a GT
and algorithmic mechanism design and it
strikes me that there is a connection to
the smoothness arguments that we've been
talking about in the sense that you know
the smoothness arguments are about
looking at a particular class of
deviations like say deviating from
whatever your equilibrium bit is to
bidding capture value and then adding up
a bunch of those incentive constraints
in order to derive a relationship
between welfare outcomes that were
interested in equilibrium and we're kind
of doing something similar you know
we're looking at the incentive
constraints where you deviate from
equilibrium up to some higher bid and
we're adding up those constraints across
all bids the
you make an equilibrium to get this
uniform upward constraint and then the
larger objects that that tells us about
is the cumulative distribution of
winning bids it gives us a restriction
on the cumulative distribution of
winning bids okay so no I think people
who work on smoothness have have done an
amazing job in a sense of generalizing
those arguments beyond one particular
mechanism and saying if I have
smoothness parameters for any given
mechanism then I can apply similar
methodology to obtain bounds we've only
done this for the first price auction
and I don't know to what extent a
similar methodology might generate
predictions about about revenue for
other mechanisms but it's an obvious
direction to go for future research so
that was the example going beyond the
example this argument generalizes to
basically any distribution of a common
value it doesn't have to be uniform it
generalizes to any number of bidders it
generalizes to any arbitrarily
correlated distribution of values where
the bidders have idiosyncratic values
that could that could differ from one
another for some of the results we do
need to assume symmetry of the value
distribution if it's an asymmetric
distribution these methods give a bound
and in the case of symmetry the band is
type so I want to spend a couple of
minutes talking about how the approach
generalizes to that broader class of
models so we can write P for the measure
over values and there are some we
basically make some smoothness
assumption on p that's kind of a
technical restriction but it nests the
common value case and independent values
cases so you should think of it as kind
of a weak condition okay and we kind of
know what happens with mass points but
the math gets Messier so for a kleenex
position this seems like the right way
to go so similar to the example we first
find a bound on revenue a lower bound by
looking
relax program and then we construct an
equilibrium that attains the bound to
prove that is the true minimum so the
relaxed program involves minimizing
expected revenue not over all of the
equilibrium objects but just over the
marginal distributions of winning bids
given the true values okay and that's
what this object is this H this is the
CDF of eyes winning bids given the true
profile of values except that it's not
actually a CDF because it's multiplied
by the probability that this guy is
going to win when these are the values
so if you sum this across all bidders I
then you'll get the cumulative
distribution of the winning bid given
the profile of values regardless of who
makes that winning bid and we only
impose a subset of view of the incentive
constraints which are these uniform
upward instead of constraints and you
can show that those constraints can be
formulated just in terms of these
cumulative distributions of winning bids
and again there's a component which is
the loss from paying more than you would
have any if you follow the equilibrium
strategy and a component which is a
potential gain from winning when you
would have lost an equilibrium and I say
potential because of course you might
end up winning on some events where your
bid is higher than your values you're
actually losing surplus there but you
might be winning enough when your value
is above your bid that that you actually
do gain from that second component yeah
substance of one substance the
realization she's third bullet is there
anything else when you
sure there are some feasibility
restrictions on H that you know they
have to be non-negative they have to be
they have to some to less than one those
we continue imposing all distributions
of winning bids aren't you losing
anything about the original problem
beyond sure I mean I don't know anything
about the distribution of losing bids I
haven't retained enough information to
evaluate whether or not there's an
incentive to pointwise deviate from a
particular equilibrium bid up to some
higher bid I can't evaluate those and I
can't say anything about whether or not
you'd want to deviate down so i have
lost a lot of information and just
because i have a solution to this relax
program that doesn't imply that it
automatically extends to an equilibrium
does that answer your question ok so the
characterization is somewhat more
involved in the example involves several
steps before symmetry of the equilibrium
was an assumption now it's a conclusion
I'm not going to take you through it
here you know in the in the common value
example efficiency wasn't a concern
everyone had the same value it didn't
matter who got the good for efficiency
purposes and the good was always
allocated just because of the way we
constructed the mechanism or what we
assumed about the mechanism but when the
bidders have idiosyncratic components to
their evaluations efficiency is a
concern ok and it's far from obvious
that minimum revenue would be obtained
in an efficient equilibrium and the
reason is that introducing some
inefficiency destroys surplus in
principle the seller might suffer from
that loss of surplus in the form of
lower revenue ok but it turns out that
actually minimum revenue has to be
obtained in an efficient allocation and
the reason is that you know when you
deviate upwards in this manner you
actually don't care what your value is
on the event when you were going to win
in equilibrium because you're still
going to win because you're deviating to
something higher what you care about the
most is what your value is when you were
going to lose in equilibrium because now
you're going to win on that event and
gain additional rents and on the whole
having lower values when you lose
induces a weaker incentive to deviate up
ok and you know what's the allocation of
the good that's going to induce the
lowest losing values well it's when you
make the the winner the guy with the
highest value ok so the efficient
allocation in some sense is aligned with
reducing the incentives to deviate up
another conclusion and this is kind of
subtle is that at the minimum for this
for this relaxed program the winning bid
is only going to depend on certain
statistics of the profile of values it's
not going to depend on all of the values
it turns out it's just going to depend
on the average of the n minus 1 lowest
values so that's what this object is
you're summing up all of the values and
then subtracting off the highest and
then dividing by n minus 1 so why the
average of the lowest values that seems
kind of arbitrary well basically it
comes from the assumptions of symmetry
ok if you uniformly deviate up to some
level be all you know is that you're
going to start winning when the when the
winning bid is B when you would have
lost in equilibrium okay but you can't
control which of the profiles you're
going to win on which of the profiles of
values you're going to win on that you
would have lost on an equilibrium and in
particular if there's a profile of
values in which you would have lost and
now you're going to win you're also
going to win on all permutations of that
profile evaluations so an expectation
you basically think that your value on
this event is going to be the average of
your value across all permutations and
combining that with the fact that you
would have lost in equilibrium you know
that you you expect your value to be the
average of the values you would have had
in the event that you lost ok
and then the final sort of pillar of the
characterization now at this point we
know that the allocation is going to be
we know that the the equilibrium is
going to be symmetric the allocation is
going to be efficient winning bids are
going to depend on the on the average of
the losing values and then the last
piece is what is going to be the
correlation structure between winning
bids and this average losing value and
it turns out that the right structure is
to have the winning bid be strictly
increasing in the average losing value
ok so these objects are going to be Co
monotonic at the minimum and the reason
is that you know for each one of these
uniform upward deviations the incentive
to deviate in that manner depends on
your expectation of your value in the
event that you would lose which is in a
sense the expectation of the average of
the losing values when that's when the
winning bid is below this level so the
incentive to deviate up is weaker if
that expectation is lower and there's a
particular correlation structure that
minimizes point wise for each uniform
upward deviation what the expectation is
of this average losing value which is to
make the to kumon and tonic if you
didn't get that don't worry about it but
the long and short of it is that there's
a final form for this relax program
which is choosing a deterministic and
strictly increasing function of the
average losing value for the winning bid
and this kind of puts us back into the
situation where we were in the toy model
where we were just optimizing over that
one function and and we can use the same
techniques as before to conclude that
all of these upward incentive
constraints are going to bind and that
pins down with this function is so the
general form for the solution turns out
to look like this q is this distribution
of the average losing value so this is
something that we derived from the prior
values F is going to be q raised to the
power n minus 1 over N and then the
winning bid the minimum winning bid
function is going to be essentially the
expectation of a random variable which
is distributed according to this F
conditional on it being below the true
value of them
I don't have a great intuition for
exactly why this is the form that the
minimum winning bid function has to have
but this is what it has to have okay so
because this was a relaxation of the
original problem we can conclude that
revenue in any equilibrium has to be at
least the expectation of this minimum
winning bid function and then the main
theorem of the paper is that there
exists an equilibrium in which the
winning bid is this deterministic
function I don't want to get on the
internet right now
there exists an equilibrium in which in
which we exactly obtain this lower bound
on revenue and this equilibrium is
efficient right and therefore this
equilibrium is also maximizing bitter
surplus basically we've maximized the
total size of the pie we've minimized in
absolute terms the amount of that pie
that the seller is going to get so we
must have also maximized the amount of
the pie that the bidders are going to
get okay so that's the main result and
and you know I suppose there is a lot to
do in the construction of the rest of
the equilibrium that attains the bounds
and in showing that all of the other
constraints are going to be satisfied in
equilibrium it's kind of an it's an
interesting process but an involved
process and so I'm not going to go into
it right now but yes well what I meant
in particular is that the solution of
this relaxed program has to be symmetric
and what symmetry means here is I have a
winning bid distribution which depends
on the profile of values if I permute
the players identities this object
should remain the same so in other words
if I swap I and J now this should be
equal to you know what Jay is winning
winning bid distribution was or if I
swap the identity values of other
players other than I this object
shouldn't change that's what i mean by
symmetry yes not that i saw wasn't
because of your paper as you guess but
from what you're showing it seems like
the kind of constraints you using would
be coordinated action movie also the
kind of single getting correlated
iquilibrium as a constraint absolutely
and the question is it is what you're
concluding applies to correlate the deck
to the bureau's oh absolutely so this is
a game of incomplete information so we
have to be more specific about what we
mean by correlated equilibrium there is
a particular notion of correlated
equilibrium which is something that was
invented by Dirk and Stephen that they
call base correlated equilibrium and
basically we're calculating minimum
revenue
overall base correlated equilibrium but
that is equivalent to the exercise of
minimizing revenue overall information
structures and Bay's Nash equilibria
that is a general characterization so
for for the purposes of this the reason
I'm asking this correlated equilibria
and learnable in the repeated setting
some sort of luring life learning that
we gon get to correlate an equilibrium
and the advantage of that is that they
don't have to know what the other
players know because learning doesn't
need so much information true so there
are people here who I would like to talk
to about this I don't know to what
extent people have extended those
learning results to incomplete
information environments but but if one
did then I suppose this would be a
prediction also about the outcome that
kind of a learning process although
those algorithms converge to a
correlated color and you don't know
which one typically so correct but if
he's giving a lower balance also we call
it the equilibrium in the strategic hall
which I don't think I'm the base
whatever call it the Collegium if you're
talking about it should be a subset I
would think of correlated equilibria of
the normal form of the game right I
think Munsen what we're doing with Jason
and Vasily we're talking about
correlated iquilibrium abutting meets is
correlated equilibria because the
upwards deviation is not that uniform
deviation is just uniform upwards but I
think that that's there won't be a
problem of course it's also a deviation
in the strategic normal form of the game
right it's it's definitely something
worth we're thinking about more okay so
I only have a couple of minutes left we
call the model that I've been talking
about so far the unknown values model
unknown values in the sense that the
bidders might not know anything about
their value except for the prior they
have to know the prior now in many
models of first price auctions or other
auction mechanisms
we assume a lot more right so in
particular you know that this might be a
sensible starting point in a common
value model we're learning about my
value is equivalent to learning about
others values so there's a very strong
strategic linkage through what you learn
about your own value but when you talk
about models with an idiosyncratic
component like for example the
independent private values model it's
often reasonable to assume that the
bidders are more informed about their
own idiosyncratic component than about
others and an extreme version of that is
an is what we call the known values
model in which you definitely know your
own value although you may have partial
information about others values and what
others know so basically we study the
known values model as well and we
conduct similar exercises of trying to
derive bounds on revenue and bitter
surplus across all information
structures that satisfy this condition
and there's kind of a natural
restriction here which we impose which
is that the bidders don't bid more than
their known value okay if you knew that
you were going to lose for sure in
equilibrium you might have an incentive
it might be instead of compatible to do
that but it's a weakly dominated
strategy so it's kind of a natural
refinement so basically we characterize
maximum revenue for the known values
model the long and short of it is that
in the unknown values model in a
symmetric setting revenue could go all
the way down up to the efficient surplus
and bitter surplus could go all the way
down to zero that's no longer the case
with known values in general the bidders
can guarantee themselves some positive
rents and we compute exactly what the
maximum rents are that the bidders can
guarantee for themselves and minimum
revenue sorry we calculate the minimum
rents that the bidders have to receive
and we calculate maximum revenue okay we
also explore minimum revenue in in the
known value setting and we attempt to
generalize the techniques that worked so
well for unknown values it turns out
that they don't generalize completely
but we can solve some special cases for
example when the bidders have two
possible value
shins higher low in that case we can
completely solve the model with n
bitters and and get a type prediction
for minimum revenue although more
generally of course unknown values is a
superset of known values so our unknown
values minimum revenue characterization
is also a lower bound on on revenue for
the known values model so this is a
gratuitous picture as Larry's Harrison
would say of the set of welfare outcomes
combinations of revenue and bitter
surplus that can obtain under these two
models the blue outline encircles the
set of outcomes that could arise under
note unknown values and then the red set
is known values and this is for the case
of two bidders who have independent
uniformly distributed values so
basically in this model this is the
efficient frontier in which the sum of
bitter surplus and revenue is maximized
there are inefficient equilibria in
which the sum of those two objects is
below the efficient frontier okay and
these are what the whole set looks like
this isn't an analytic characterization
this is obtained computationally
although we have analytic
characterizations for various features
this frontier this point and this point
and some stuff along here the talk has
been about minimizing revenue in the
unknown values model and maximizing
bitter surplus and the unknown values
model this one was trivial because this
is when the seller gets everything in
the bidders get nothing in the common
value model it's not trivial in the in
the general model and then I briefly
mentioned results about this point
so let me wrap up you know they're a
bunch of applications that one can
imagine for this work and we do some of
them we think about what would be the
effect of introducing some kind of
exclusion device are there a reserve
price or an entry fee into the auction
we know that in the classical setting of
independent private values that can
raise revenue and it seems like it can
also raise revenue here although it's
really just a computational exercise
that we do another application is you
know there's a there's a large
literature in economics on auction
econometrics we observe some
distribution of bids and we want to back
out the fundamentals of the model that
gave rise to those bids as an
equilibrium phenomenon but that
literature typically make strong
assumptions like for example ipv or
affiliated private values so question is
are there you know there are some
obvious applications of this result to
identification I have a distribution of
winning bids and I know that whatever
the true environment is the minimum
distribution has to be lower than what I
observed in the sense of first order
stochastic dominance and that imposes a
restriction on what the true
distribution of values can be and then
you know as I was briefly mentioning we
look at some other directions in welfare
space how low could efficiency go I
suppose there is a nice connection that
I should mention which is that there are
results that that I believe Ava has
worked on and vasilis seganus on lower
bounds on efficiency in known values
models that apply to this general
setting actually and it's kind of a
remarkable feature of this computation
that known values minimum surplus is so
much higher than unknown values minimum
surplus in fact for this independent
value setting in symmetric setting you
can show that surplus could go all the
way down to completely always miss
allocating the good in other words there
is an information structure and an
equilibrium in which the winner is
always the bitter with the lowest value
I'm not going to construct it for you
now but it will be good coffee
conversation in a few minutes hopefully
but in the known values case that
can happen and minimum surplus is
significantly higher ok so I'll wrap up
you know in future work we're hoping to
extend this methodology to understand
other mechanisms and then super long
term goal would be you know thinking
about mechanism design from the
perspective of max min where I don't
know what the equilibrium will be and I
don't know what the information
structure is so thanks
answer all of your questions
preemptively
thanks